hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to final nights 3 hey hi
what do I do
I don't know what to do Oh God wind oh
hi how's it going I'm just gonna stare
death in the face cuz I another
alternative oh you got a lovely smile I
don't know how to play Oh what what am i
doing what am i doing I don't know
what's happening that's one intimidating
clock right there a great big clock
coming are you good son I can't do
anything pressing buttons why did I go
confront him
really I'm expecting something to pop
out but apparently nothing wants to say
hi to me I must be so adorable when I
sleep you clip creep and click creepily
bring in we were just having a bromance
and you you made it all weird certainly
not gonna shove this fork into this
power plug here baby baby baby
that's one intimidating clock right
there a great big